in this video we'll talk about
autonomous specification
autonomous sulfate specification is a
process where a developing cell is able
to differentiate without any external
signal as if the cell knows what it has
to become in future
so it's kind of like a self-drive it
doesn't need any external influence it's
a inbuilt molecular program that is
driving the cells fate into its
terminally differentiated stage
so let us talk about cell
differentiation in bit more details and
try to understand the nuts and bolts so
cell differentiation is a stepwise long
process let us look at this journey so
imagine this is a stem cell and it's a
starting point of the journey and let's
look at the whole journey towards a
differentiated cell
so there could be transient cell States
where the cell's fate is specified
so specification is kind of like a
commitment step which is still liable I
mean there could be alterations at this
stage as well and there is another stage
of this commitment process which is
irreversible commitment and this is
known as determination
where the cell has to become what it
should become and there is no reversal
at this point and there is terminally
differentiated state in this case the
terminally differentiated state is the
neuron
now in this days we know all these kind
of features and stages that occurs
during the process of differentiation
back in 9
teens when these phenomena were
discovered very little was known about
it an autonomous specification was
discovered in that point of time
and the groundbreaking work was done on
very simple organism which is snail so
in snail Petula there is specific cells
which are ciliated and these cells are
specified by a specific blastomere at 16
cell stage you can see the Truffle
blasts are in red in color
so these cells would eventually give
rise to ciliated cells during the larval
stage
scientists have shown that yes in the
intact embryo these cells are destined
to become ciliated cells but if these
cells are removed these strokoblast
cells are removed and left alone in a
dish still they have the capability to
become that ciliated still a ciliated
cell as if
similar things are happening in vitra as
well this kind of experiments those
simple it tells us that okay there are
intrinsic Drive coming in from the cell
that is driving the differentiation
but the question is how is this possible
what is this intrinsic drive as if the
cell knows what it wants to become in
life
so it has to take this kind of fate and
it would prevent
other alternative Fates
so scientists thought
what are the nature of molecular program
what are these intrinsic signal what are
the chemical nature of these signals and
how these messages are interpreted by
the cell these questions were key to
understand the autonomous specification
process
so and the idea comes from
people thought that okay the idea might
be hidden in the U site
so the egg cytoplasm might not be a
homogeneous region it might be highly
heterogeneous there could be
compartments of different molecules and
each different compartments are
selectively segregated during blastomere
formation
such that one blastomer gets one
particular kind of signal other
blastomere gets completely different
kind of signal and these intrinsic
messages determine what that particular
blastomere would eventually become in an
adult in an adult or an in an embryonic
litter embryonic stage
so the whole idea about autonomous
specification is the cell knows at the
very early stage what it's going to
become later on
but the scientists were still
understanding or trying to understand
what was the cytoplasmic determinant is
it an protein is it an transcription
factor it's an micro RNA long non-coding
RNA it could be anything right
so this idea came from tunicates which
are lower organism they are C squirts so
the this experiment was actually this
observation was actually made by Edwin
Grant Conklin so he found and he
observed that there is kind of like a
yellow coloration in the
egg cytoplasm ultimately this yellow
coloration was observed in the tail
muscles so the muscle lineage has this
kind of like yellow coloration so this
kind of Fate map was proposed by Edwin
Grand Conklin
So eventually when the blastomeres
segregate they they found that okay the
B 4.1 blastomere is associated with
muscle lineages
now elegant experiments very simple but
elegant they dissociated these
blastomias they dissociated them into
individual cells
and grow them separately in petri dish
under some media and they found out that
each of these cells eventually becomes
the cell that they are about to make in
the intact embryo that means the B 4.2
blastomeres and a 4.2 blastomeres are
destined to become ectoderm in the
embryo and they are also making ectoderm
in the dish
whereas B 4.1 is making muscles a 4.1 is
making notochord and portion of the
endoderm
so this kind of Fate is kind of like
preserved even if it is done outside the
body in the in vitro situation and this
can be only possible if there is an
internal drive or internal cue which is
telling the cell what to become
eventually
still they have no clue about the nature
of the signal
several years down the line around 1970s
it was discovered that this particular
yellow coloration or this kind of
pigmentation that occurs that might have
specific mRNA known as Macho this Macho
would eventually be really useful for
muscle differentiation this is a
transcription factor that triggers
muscle differentiation
so how did people know about it so
scientists did elegant experiment so
this is how the Macho expression look
like in the control so this is in situ
hybridization where in the purple images
shows muscle marker actin so whenever
you see these purple coloration that
means okay in that particular portion
muscle would be developed
so they actually eliminated Macho with
antisense probes and they found out that
when Macho is depleted muscle marker
actin also goes down as if the muscle is
not formed
and when they put Macho in a different
blastomere instead of b 4.1 they put
Macho in different other blastomeres
there is ectopic development of muscles
that means Macho was the key determinant
of this autonomous specification and
this was one of the Breakthrough in uh
the developmental biology field people
understood that how intrinsic signal can
guide cellular fate and that was the
basis of understanding autonomous
specification
now let me tell you that autonomous
specification is not the only way of
selfish specification
after looking at autonomous
specification don't think that there is
no external influence required for a Fed
specification of cells this is only one
of the way by which sulphate
specification can be achieved
so let me tell you a little bit more
idea about other kind of specification
which happens in higher eukaryotes
so
self weight of a tissue is said to be
specified when it is capable of
differentiating autonomously in a
neutral environment so imagine this is a
particular cell which is specified to
become muscle
and we put it in a petri dish
So eventually it would become muscle
another cell which was specified to
become neuron we put it in a dish it
would eventually become a neuron so the
environment is neutral no external
signal it would be able to become
what it should become
but let's say there are environmental
modifiers let's say we put the same
muscle cells
in vicinity of several neurons
so the environment is highly
heterogeneous right now in this case
it's also possible that the neurons
would influence
and give some kind of like external
influence such that these muscle cells
are supposed to become neurons
so moral of the story the environment
can modify sulfate and cell commitment
is still liable at specification stage
so during specification stage external
influences also matter
so this is another kind of specification
that is happening in higher eukaryotes
like vertebrates so about these kind of
specification we would be talking about
later but autonomous specification was
first reported in lower organisms like
snails like sea squirts
and we also looked at the mechanism by
which autonomous specification can occur
so I hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up and
don't forget to follow my Instagram or
Facebook page for notes support our
Channel using super tanks see you in
next video
okay
[Music]